dot com new plans in North Las Vegas to
redevelop the demolished Fiesta Rancho
and Texas Station casino sites that's
right the 73 Acres had become a huge
complex of new homes as well as
businesses City officials have their
first discussion tomorrow and our Lauren
Negrete is live at Rancho and Lake Mead
with a closer look Lauren good morning
hey good morning yes Agora Realty wants
to turn this big dirt lot behind me here
into a major retail and residential area
now as far as what that project entails
according to North Las Vegas city
documents the project named Hilo
includes 665 residential units a hotel
restaurant and various other businesses
plus two ice rinks the current one out
here will be turned into an indoor field
house Agora Realty CEO says they're
envisioning a family-oriented walkable
Community once completed staff says
it'll supply nearly a thousand new jobs
North Las Vegas City Planning staff does
recommend approval with some conditions
now because they are so close to the
north Las Vegas Airport the developers
have to get FAA approval for some parts
of the plan again construction should
start next year early next year out here
live Laura Negrete 8 news now back to
you guys oh thanks for the update a lot
of folks been wondering